[Music]
congratulations your honor you are
coming up on 24 years of marriage to
your husband Kevin Bacon that's amazing
you know in this business where people
say you know to celebrities that they
can't last you know what I mean
yeah no it's lasted it's been good how
underwhelming romantic it's been so
great the funny thing is is that he I
mean he was he never thought it would
last either let me tell you the story
wait Kevin didn't think that you guys
would last yeah but this was a long time
ago okay so we met doing a movie called
lemon sky and we were in Cambridge
Massachusetts and I wasn't really
interested in hooking up or whatever it
is that the kids say these days that's
what we say yeah so every night after
work he was very few know friendly and
sweet and every night after work he
would invite the Hulk you'd say who
wants to go out to dinner and the whole
cast would say yes except for me and
later on he told me that the only person
he wanted to say yes was me and I never
said yes and he was always stuck with
the check
poor guy anyway so one day you know a
couple weeks into the shoot we were
doing a scene and he was massaging baby
oil on my back in the theme Oh as part
of the scene in a scene I was gonna say
he's a confident operator she won't talk
to me
splurge
and so he said to me you know you're
really tight I have you ever had a
massage worst line ever
and I thought best line yeah actually
you're right so I said you know no I
hadn't I actually had him at that time
you said you know there's this really
great massage therapist at my hotel we
were staying in separate hotels and and
he said you should make his appointment
to go see her and you know it just so
happens that the the gym of the massage
room is in the gym and if I happen to be
finished with you know my workout when
you're finished with your massage maybe
we can get dinner and I'm thinking yeah
sure that's not gonna happen I mean I'm
not gonna tell them when my massages so
shocker I get out of my massage like
that weekend
and who's just stepping off the
Stairmaster whoo what an exhausting
workout I thought you're gonna say
efficient on the sudden he was in the
room so he's getting off the Stairmaster
yeah later on you're told I mean I
completely bought it I thought it was
just a coincidence years later he told
me it actually called downstairs and
asked when I was getting massaged which
is kind of creepy but whatever let him
know yeah oh yeah yeah women the worst
but I'll tell you exactly when she's
done yeah
by the way we don't know who you are
straight now
but you two you're great couple you get
along obviously quite well it's all
worked out and and it's it's interesting
to me because you are very well-spoken
you seem very polite but you often
embarrass Kevin and a lot of spouses do
this with their I do what I say actually
my family calls me La Boca Grande and
it's it's a loving it's a loving phrase
but basically I put my foot in my mouth
all the time you know say you say things
that embarrass him constantly constantly
actually when I first moved to New York
I I was about nine well no sorry when I
moved out to LA I had a dog and then
when I went back to New York I they
didn't allow dogs on public
transportation there's of course you
know and so I used to walk the dog all
the time and and you never take him on
public transportation and one day I
actually was on the bus without the dog
and there was this man there and he had
a dog and it was kind of tucked
underneath you know the the seat and I
said gosh you know that's so amazing do
that I didn't know that they allowed
dogs on buses and he goes they don't I'm
blind and I got really uncomfortable and
I said oh some people have all the luck
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
with you yeah I was trying to make light
yeah did you wanna make light he
forgives you you guys get along you've
you've stood the test of time oh yeah
for sure for sure